hello everybody oh I just love this song
okay all right I never that
[Music]
got a little overexcited there that's
just the way it goes where am i where am
i where am i did I fall what's going on
what's going on where am I
oh no wait oh hang on maybe this is the
wrong maybe that's the wrong save nope
shut up shut up shut up song no oh no I
fell
Bob Bozak but alright markiplier balzac
uh uh no it's not our here yeah
whoa uh okay I was confused there for a
second
[Applause]
we will wait for you no control has been
taken away from you don't even know I
don't even know I don't even I don't
even want to know I didn't even think I
dunno oh goodness oh goodness hell I
turned my back to him but he didn't kill
me I don't think that's how it works
this one oh I thought it got me huh how
where'd you go oh you son of a whoa huh
say wha
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't think I actually don't think the
light changes when I have the mess
my ears holy crap that static is balls
to the walls loud oh man
we're yet this time buddy pal friend Oh
I'll try to I'll try to make sure that
you guys go
don't go death from those things
whenever that happens cuz I mean it's
freaking loud oh man mother of fudge
golly jiminy Christmas
I actually don't have it turned up that
loudmouth blody
oh my I didn't even start my timer I
have no idea how long I've been playing
I'm just gonna have to guess oh man that
that's killing me
oh of course
oh hi hi hi friend you're gonna scream
in my ear again please don't
I'd rather you didn't cool thanks for
that oh I don't like this game I don't
think I'll be playing this game much in
the future it's just dark as balls in
here what whoa what I can't see anything
what why what happened
I can't see a thing I can't see a thing
I can't see anything what happened where
am I
oh no I'm like totally lost what
happened how what why is it pitch-black
now I'm trying I'm trying guys I just I
don't know what happened
son of a [ __ ] damn it oh god oh god oh
man I don't even know how he behaves
anymore because sometimes when I like
turned away from him to run he didn't
just get me like I don't know I I don't
know what the deal is I don't know I
really don't know
[Applause]
okay lead him to the Ark I don't know
what the Ark is but Oh thanking this key
card level 1f I was hoping for a level
two but I'll take what I can get some
more documents Oh what dot oh this is
different how let me read this we just
moved into this cabin I'm so excited to
play the endless forest it's gonna be
great I hope I find some cool things in
the forest maybe dinosaur bones or
something I can't wait to explore dear
diary I went into the forest I saw
something so strange it looked like a
man in a suit but I couldn't get a good
look at him he was too far away I didn't
know anyone else was that far out in the
woods I thought my family and I were the
only ones out here and they had just
been my imagination dear diary I'm
feeling drawn to the forest more than
usual and I don't know why maybe that
man I saw wasn't part of my imagination
when I saw him it felt like he was
calling to me what does he want
I wonder what he wants dear diary I saw
that man again but he's in a man he's a
thing and it it's not human it has no
face when I was close to it I was frozen
staring into the nothingness that had
claimed its face in his arms its Long's
arms they look like branches there sis
then his body was tall like a tree
that's that thing reached for me I ran
as fast as I could back home I tried to
tell mommy and daddy but they didn't
believe me only you believe me diary
okay there's a little kid dear diary
what does it want I think there's less
time I'm gonna write him in my diary
from the moment I saw that thing a
couple days ago he's been taking me over
it's been in my dreams I've seen symbols
in my sleep a circle with an X through
it I've seen the tall man not only in my
sleep but in my room at night standing
in the corner and waiting for me to
sleep it's like it wants me to sleep
I've been unable to
it's driving me crazy what does it want
what does it want this is the last
century I can't run away anymore
there isn't any running I think once
you've seen him you could never escape
ok so that's new well don't tell me that
oh no wait
this is the thing I need a higher
ranking card you're kidding me
ah fudge what goes it what good is a
level one anyway ok where did that come
from over there
Oh balls Balzac oh this is a bad seed
[Music]
there's a bad seed
ok I think I came from there or it's a
good seed cuz they're all dark and quiet
for once uh-huh for once it's actually
quiet ok what's the deal here it's
really dark I can't see anything oh no
ok maybe it's just a smidge dark oh oh
he's jumping all over the place not
gonna give me a not gonna get that
noises his loud as balls dark again I'll
take it off and didn't make a difference
was that I don't know I don't know
I don't know anything anymore I just
pretend to know things I don't think so
now higher higher security clearance Oh
Oh give me a card give me a card Oh give
me a card give me a card that's not card
is this nope ah what is this
nope ah drop that maybe I am supposed to
collect his pages I don't know maybe
maybe that'll do something huh man no
card this is where I tried to say before
didn't quite work out
leave me alone you're the one following
me man I swear the ambient sounds in
this and this thing are just horrific
ah come on I need something
give me some here card balls what was
that
oh man I hate this game
I can't hear a damn thing
Oh balls
Oh
oh man
aha no other game that I've ever played
is [ __ ] with me this much
[Applause]
oh I just don't like it I just don't
like all of this I don't know what that
was coming out of the floor but who who
is anything like the old man radical
Larry as he's called I didn't want to be
near him oh oh why is it dark there why
is that dark okay there we go got
another one
all right wait do I have it on or off
okay on I hear the breathing oh man
punch I would just be okay with if the
loud noises would stop some noises are
getting to me
oh this looks good I love this one
always not there for once
oh don't tell me he's behind this story
anything oh no oh if that I know what
the deal is are for those of you don't
know think Oh where'd he go what
happened
think he didn't break the glass hated it
did
dud okay Oh give me card Oh another one
of these items
[Music]
okay all right then what was that oh god
I don't even know okay here we go please
be level two yes
Oh finally something good is happening I
think I think I'm not exactly sure cuz
they didn't start my timer accidentally
they think I'm all out of time so I'm
gonna cut it here thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye